[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GREY: Very excited
to have Karen here.
Karen has a long and
storied history at Google.
She joined Google in 2002,
and was here through 2011,
and worked as a media liaison.
Really launched a
lot of the things
that you've taken for
granted here at Google,
including the blog and
our Twitter account.
And much of our outbound
has flowed through her
and come from her ideas.
She later went on to be an
editorial director at Twitter,
and was there, I
think, six years?
KAREN WICKRE: About five.
LOUIS GREY: About five.
We'll give her five.
And so she's had, really,
kind of a firsthand
experience at some of the
biggest names in tech,
and really, the world.
And you've had a
front-row seat to that.
And it's been interesting to see
your career flourish and grow,
even after you left this
small little company.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was good to
see your stories when
you wrote this book, which
is "Taking the Work Out
of Networking," which
is really an introvert's
guide to networking.
One thing that's been
fun for me to see
is that I feel like
everybody knows Karen,
or they've known of her, or
she has been one step away
from other people that we know.
And I managed to go
through this book
and really take a lot out of it.
And so I'm glad you're
here to talk about it.
KAREN WICKRE: Oh, me too.
LOUIS GREY: And we probably have
a few introverts in the room
who could benefit from it.
[LAUGHTER]
So first, why don't
you tell us why
did you write a
book for introverts?
KAREN WICKRE: Well, I'm
thrilled to be here.
I love Google, and
I've long loved Google,
so it's great to be back
in the plex, as it were.
I wrote the book to see
if I could break down
in detail the things I have done
to create a big virtual network
for myself.
And it wasn't that I woke
up one day and said, wow,
I have a fantastic network.
It's more that other
people over the years
have often said to me, you
seem to know everybody.
And I would be the one for
the hot years in Google,
as he said, as Louis said,
I was here from 2002,
when hiring really turned
up, and Google was getting
a million resumes a year.
It might still.
I don't know.
But there was a point where
that started to happen.
And I was getting inundated
from all my other contacts
everywhere.
I want to work at Google.
And I generally will say yes
to most meetings, or calls,
or Hangouts, or something.
I would connect with
everybody that had questions.
The answers would
vary, obviously,
depending on a lot of things.
But during that time, as I was
sort of telling people maybe
how to go about navigating
Google, and applying to Google,
and thinking about it, it
led me to think, how can I
codify how people not
just do a job search,
but also, like, be able
to call on other people
when they have questions,
when they need something,
because we all
have those moments?
So fast forward a
few years, and I
wrote a column for what used to
be called "Backchannel" which
is now part of "WIRED."
Steven Levy was the editor.
And it was essentially
building off
of my many meetings
with either job
seekers or people that wanted
to move into tech businesses
from some more traditional
industry, or something
like that.
And I went through
the same thing.
And I thought, I need
to really detail this.
So fast forward again,
I've left Twitter.
I got a book agent, and a couple
of New York editors called me,
and we kicked around a
bunch of ideas for books.
And finally, someone asked me,
what is the one piece of advice
that you find yourself
always giving people?
And I said, it is to
build a network for life.
Introvert didn't
really come into it
except I'm an introvert.
So I've not built a
network on the basis
of me being a famous celebrity.
Not only am I not that,
but I much more prefer
a background role.
And I still have done it, and so
that's what made me think, OK.
Let me break this
out for people.
So the book is for introverts,
but not only introverts,
because in the
process of doing it,
I discovered everybody
hates networking.
Everybody hates the idea.
Everybody thinks of it as a
chore, and that it's phony.
And it doesn't seem to
yield much very effectively.
So I thought, this is the way
I want to go is make something,
approach in a way that's more
useful for all kinds of people.
LOUIS GREY: You talk about
networking being a chore.
I think most people, you
said they don't like it.
They don't want to do it.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And that's
especially true for introverts.
Many times when you
talk about networking,
you're talking about it from
the phase of a job seeker.
KAREN WICKRE: Yes.
LOUIS GREY: And yet,
there are people
who have stable jobs who
don't plan on leaving.
So who cares?
So why would somebody
who's in a stable job
want to do networking, and
why is it important for them?
KAREN WICKRE: Who
among us thinks
you have a stable job for the
rest of your working life?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, honestly,
I've talked to people
who did think that until their
job wasn't stable, right?
Until you name
any kind of change
happened that they weren't happy
with, or lots of circumstances
happen.
And so the idea that it's a
kind of one and done thing,
it just isn't reality
for most of us anymore.
But I also think the value
of one's personal connections
and contacts, or
as the subtitle,
"Making Connections that Count,"
is really something we do
want to be able to call on
people who have subject matter
expertise, and experience
in a specific thing
when we're looking for
that specific thing.
So job's a big
category, but not only.
But I have literally talked
to people who have said,
I'm coming to you because
I let my network go.
How do I start again?
Because I've been in a job I've
been happy in for a long time.
And now, I need
to make a change.
LOUIS GREY: So one
thing I run into,
and you've talked
about it in the book,
was that there's this
perception that networking
or the process of it requires
you to not be yourself, and be
fake, to put an artificial
representation of yourself,
and filter out the
things you don't
think people want to know.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: Do you
find that that's
true or do you find by being
your true self in full,
you have the most access to
new people and new ideas?
KAREN WICKRE: I think
when you're authentic,
and you're not in the clutch
of fear and neediness,
and feeling the need to be in a
transactional mode with someone
you don't know at all, that's
a position of vulnerability,
to be sure.
That's not fun for the
person who's in it.
But the more you find
common points of connection,
even with people you
don't know, the easier
it will be to remember later.
Oh, that person was easy to
talk to, or I liked that person.
Maybe they're going
to know about this,
or I know they do know about
this other thing I'm asking,
a different role a
different company,
They lived in another country
I'm thinking of whatever it is.
That person is approachable.
And I think that's the
way that we all want
to connect with each other.
And so why not put it to
practice as we go along?
LOUIS GREY: In 2000, as the
dotcom bubble was popping,
and you start to-- if you
look at your LinkedIn,
they start to be instead
of five-year chunks,
they're like one-year
chunks, right?
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And I
think a lot of people
in the valley, especially,
you talk about it that they
have three-year job cycles.
So you came to the end of one
of these one-year job cycles,
and it was really hard
to find a dedicated role,
and it was for a
lot of your peers.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And you talk about
this story of you creating
almost like a support group.
KAREN WICKRE: I did.
LOUIS GREY: Where you
connect to each other
and say, so how's it going?
And as you told
it, that eventually
led you to a contract role at
Google a couple years later.
So why was this your job?
How did it fall to you to
put together this group?
Because that shows to me
someone who isn't necessarily
that introvert, stay at home
role, but more of a leader.
How did you get this?
KAREN WICKRE:
Well, I don't think
those are opposite things.
So I am an introvert
stay at home
when it comes to if I've had
kind of a long stretch of being
out and about.
The mental calculation is,
how soon can I go home?
Like, when can I
get some respite
from being out in the world?
But I go back out
into the world.
So the thing I really am at
root is a connector of people.
And I also thought
it was true, there
was this big downturn
in 2000, 2001.
Nobody was hiring.
Jobs just melted away.
I mean, it was a first for the
Bay Area, for Silicon Valley.
And so I knew a bunch of
people who had been looking.
And now, there were no
jobs listed anymore.
So I thought, well, we need
to keep each other going.
So I asked a few people I knew,
and some better than others,
some former work colleagues.
I think there were
eight of us or so.
And we would meet around my
dining room table in the city.
I think we met weekly, but it
might have been less frequent.
But the idea was
talk over what leads
you're finding, if you need
help describing yourself,
or if you want to be
for the time being
a consultant, what
are your services?
What's your pricing?
Let's just kick it around,
because we got to kind of feel
our way through this.
And that group did meet
for probably the better
part of two years, on
and off, just because it
was a long period of people
practicing their elevator
pitch, or maybe I'm going
to be interested in this,
and I got to go do some
research about that.
It was a good lesson for me.
And I think I do turn to
other people for advice
and for guidance.
And I want those people
to be not random,
but people who know
the environment I'm in,
know what I'm interested in.
And that was kind of the
purpose of this group, too.
So I did go.
I did move from my support
group at the dining room table
to a contract as a marketing
writer for Google in 2002.
However, I knew the
first VP of Comms here,
whose name was Cindy McCaffrey,
because I'd worked with her
at two other companies prior.
So I'd kept up with her.
I'd visited Google
not on university,
but in the first of the office
park complexes just over here.
The other thing I had
been doing is freelance
writing for trade publications.
So I actually reviewed
Google as a search engine in,
I don't know, something
like maybe 2000, just as
a freelance thing.
And I remember that's
how I knew Google
was that I'd looked at it, and
it was so many leagues better
than all the other 20 search
engines that had come before.
So I thought, wow.
They've got something.
This thing really works.
I gave it a good review.
Anyway, I came to have
lunch with Cindy one day,
and I thought, wow,
that's interesting.
And I just kept
in touch with her.
I did call her when I was on
the lookout for freelance work.
And initially, she said, we
just hired a marketing writer.
So right now, we're fine,
but I'll keep you in mind.
And then she called
me back and said,
actually, we're
drowning in work,
and that guy had
to go on a leave.
How soon can you come down?
And so it was September 3, 2002.
I do not forget this date.
And it wasn't just
a matter of Cindy.
Then, I had to meet
other people on the team,
and start talking about
specific projects I'd be doing.
And within a couple
of weeks, I thought,
this is where I want to be.
And rather than work at home
and send things in, I said,
I'm just going to be here,
and make them get sick of me.
I'm going to be here and remind
them that I want a job here.
And it took a while, but
that was how it happened.
LOUIS GREY: Yeah.
And you mentioned earlier, you
made a comment about Google
getting a million job applicants
in a day trying to get in.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: So that sounds
like the world's changed a bit.
You've gone from 2000,
where there's not
enough jobs
available, and trying
to get into a small company
of 600 or so when you started.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: To literally Tens
of thousands when you left.
And I hate to say it, but it's
gotten bigger since you left.
KAREN WICKRE: I know.
I know.
I left at 50,000 when
the Motorola acquisition
went through.
LOUIS GREY: And so there's
been a lot of change.
And you were kind of a front-row
seat to a lot of that change.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: So how did
that change your approach
to both networking
and communication?
Because now, you have
this tremendous stage,
and you have all of these
people who want your attention,
and you have to be
a filter as well.
KAREN WICKRE: Right.
So on the first part of that,
the thing that I learned
at Google that I'd never
worked for a company
that had grown so big so fast.
People had said to me, you have
to be kind of entrepreneurial
when you're at Google.
You have a lot of room to
explore and make things happen.
I didn't know what that meant,
really, at the beginning.
It didn't really sink in.
But the thing that I did
discover pretty early,
I was part of the
communications team
when I finally did
get a full-time job.
Communications as a
team has a wider view
of a company than almost any
other team, because between all
the people on their
beats, they're
aware of corporate stuff,
product stuff, employee stuff.
I mean, as a group,
collectively,
they have a really
wide horizon, which
I did like, because I
worked with everybody.
I was a floating--
I was an editor.
I was essentially like
the editor that became
the editor of the Google blog.
And so in that
process, not only was
I working with different
people along the way,
but I also realized as I
became friendly with people,
they became like my brain trust
to help me understand what's
happening around the company.
Not secret launch plans,
but more like early on,
I have liberal arts degrees.
I really didn't even
understand a search index
in the beginning.
So if I was friendly with
an engineer who did know--
and they did--
I could, like, help
me understand this.
And out of that came the
original thing that was called
Google Zeitgeist, which
is now Google Trends.
But at the time, it
was a hand-picked
from the index printed
out 50 sheets of paper
highlighting things that
we thought were spikes.
I mean, it was primitive, but
he was very patient with me
and helped me understand
what that was about.
So then when I had questions
about things like that,
I could go to someone
like him and say,
does this make sense to you?
As I began to understand more,
he was, like, a good reality
check.
And so were other people across
legal, and product, and product
marketing, and just
different ones.
I mean, Peter has been
here all this time,
and we used to work on
the mighty Google Research
blog, which was anomalous
to the other blogs,
but it was awesome.
It had its own personality.
So I think you have to
have your internal network,
especially in a big company,
that are just informal friends.
Companies not this
big, you can imagine
people saying at
the water cooler,
I'm so excited about that launch
tomorrow, and somebody saying,
really?
Does legal know about that
yet, because I'm not--
that, I hope, doesn't
happen here anymore.
But you can
appreciate that it has
a value to ongoing business.
But it also just
enriches your experience
so that you understand all
the parts of the business,
and who's doing
what, and that people
are looking after and
focused on different things.
To me, it's very enriching.
And I don't know how you
can navigate in a company
today and not do that.
LOUIS GREY: And so
networking itself
is kind of a private
activity in a lot of cases.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: It's
talking one-to-one.
KAREN WICKRE: It's
not broadcast.
LOUIS GREY: You mentioned
Peter by his first name,
because to you, he's Peter.
To a lot of these other
people in this room,
he's that guy
sitting over there.
And so you have a different
level of knowledge
based on how well you know them.
So you were able to see
Google transform in two ways.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: First was going
from private company to public,
and the second in
terms of having
that one-to-one
relationship with reporters
to the point where you
can broadcast on your own
with the blog and Twitter later.
And this is kind of a
dual-pronged question.
Take us through those stories,
because a lot of these people
weren't in the room.
Talk about going public
at Google and Twitter.
You did it twice.
KAREN WICKRE: Yes.
LOUIS GREY: And then
talk about, how did you
get a company to go
public with a blog
and start to share with
the rest of the world?
KAREN WICKRE: So Google is
a fantastic story about this
because Google bought Pyro Labs
in 2003, which was Blogger.
And from the beginning,
the comms team,
we all said, this
is what we should
use for our own publishing, a
sort of corporate publishing
mechanism, instead
of press releases,
which was the old-fashioned way.
Google didn't put out that many
press releases to begin with,
and it's a very arcane way of
doing things, not Google style.
So there was not a lot of
opposition to the concept
at all.
The question was
more, well, what's
the approval flow, and the
workflow, and things like that?
And it took a while
because I think we first
announced and
published or unveiled
the Google blog in
the spring of 2004
after we had filed for the IPO.
So the lawyers were
great, but they were also
a little wary
about, this all has
to be under the rules
of business as usual.
No wild stuff here on blogs.
At that time, people were very
anxious about corporate blogs,
because typically, it was
more like individual employees
doing it, right,
rather than a company.
In fact, the Blogger
guys at the time
said, a company
can't have a blog.
And I said, it's just
a publishing platform.
Yes, they can, and
we're going to.
So eventually, we got going.
But if you look back at the very
beginning of the Google blog,
it's like, here's a
recipe from Charlie.
It was the safest, most
non-newsworthy stuff,
because that was all we
could get past the lawyer.
So it took getting past the IPO,
and then getting some cadence.
And then eventually,
I could institute
an editorial calendar.
Because I was on
the comms team, I
made sure all the comms
people were signed off
on the individual topics.
Individual team members
from the relevant team
would be the writer, or at
least drafter of the thing,
because they were the
subject matter experts.
That was from the beginning.
And I didn't realize it
then, but Google really
paved the way for what
other companies do
in terms of their own
news and information,
because I made
sure it wasn't just
product announcement,
product announcement.
I wanted interesting
stories to come through.
And then over time, more
countries, more products all
wanted their own blogs.
And at one point, I think we
were up above 200-something.
And that's why there's
now this streamlined thing
that my wonderful successor
Emily Wood has put into place.
And Twitter, adding Google
as a Twitter account
was something I made
a case for internally.
It was 2009.
The techies were
already busy on Twitter,
and so were tech reporters,
so that was my argument.
We had to have a presence
there because tech reporters
were using it already.
And initially, I
got some pushback,
because at 2009, Google had
plenty of public channels.
And I just said, because of
the kind of company we are,
we have to be there.
And initially, it was, well,
we don't have headcount.
And I said, you
don't need headcount.
I can do this.
It's not a 24/7 job.
And so I did get the OK to
do it, which was awesome.
And the first tweet was, "I'm
feeling lucky" in binary, which
was a big hit at the time,
just because it was different,
and it sort of announced us.
So I'm happy that
I was part of that,
and that's how those
things happened.
Now, Twitter is like a
different generation,
practically, in terms it--
as a company publishing
its own stuff.
Yes, of course, they
had a Twitter account.
But by the time I got there,
the founders were all gone,
so they didn't have a voice
of Twitter biz anymore.
And it was, frankly,
a bigger challenge
to have Twitter, the
company, represented
on its own platform, ironically.
And they had less to
talk about, and there was
less they wanted to talk about.
It was not a great time
at Twitter back then.
So it was tougher to
get a cadence going,
but I did institute the
same idea of principles
about what the blog
should be talking about,
and all the names that should
be attached to post, and stuff.
And then it has morphed a
lot, even since I've left,
in terms of how they do it.
I mean, so much has
changed, really,
even in the last five years,
in terms of company news
and information.
LOUIS GREY: So we talked about
this a little bit over lunch,
but working at both
Twitter and Google,
you've had to work
with some seriously
introverted leadership, right?
And so how do you
encourage people
to whom networking
is not very easy,
and speaking publicly is
not very easy to actually go
out and do that?
How do you tell them
this is a valuable thing
and get them to engage?
KAREN WICKRE: Well,
fortunately, that
didn't all fall to me to do.
My goal was always to be
genuine and helpful, honestly.
And so I was in situations
where I could do that,
but I was not the advisor
talking about media
opportunities as much.
I did know that someone
like Steven Levy, who's
an editor-at-large
at "WIRED" now,
who's the guy who wrote
the big book about Google,
he was a perfect comfort
level for lots of people here.
And that made it a lot easier
for him to get access and write
that book.
And if you don't
know it, I think
it's still a good
book to explain
how Google approaches problems
and thinks about things.
LOUIS GREY: And
that's "In the Plex."
KAREN WICKRE: "In the Plex."
So it depended on--
I mean, I would never
be in a situation
to push a broadcast
TV interview.
Other people would do that.
But I could suggest maybe
the more offbeat sources that
had credibility, or the more
interesting ones that were not
necessarily the
biggest following,
but maybe had influence in
areas that the founders or some
of the executives
would care about.
LOUIS GREY: You
talked about blogs,
and obviously Twitter having
its own Twitter account, which
brings us into this new
generation, like you said,
of social networking.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And so
in your book, you
go through and talk about a
mix of real-life networking
and also social networking.
What do you think that
percentage should look like?
Can someone get away with
being a keyboard jockey,
and just doing email, and
just tweeting just enough,
and just posting
Instagram just enough so
that you have that
kind of loose ties
that you reference
constantly in your book?
KAREN WICKRE: A presence, yeah.
Yeah, you can.
I mean, that's part of
the point of my book
is I wasn't, like, conferred
with a lot of power
and visibility that people
would want to connect
to me, which is typically how--
that's how and maybe Tony
Robbins does it, right?
But for most of us,
it's more, I mean,
you want to be your
genuine self and be
open to meeting new and
interesting people now
and again, essentially.
It's not a 24/7 calling.
So I do believe that the
various social channels make
it possible to discover, and
meet, and have relationships
with people, with many
more people than was
ever possible without
that, for sure.
But it's not a
numbers game, either.
And so there's nothing that
can beat a one-to-one exchange,
however the other
connections work.
And in a way, I learned
that at Google, too,
because it was the first truly
international company I worked
for, where we'd have
global offsite once a year,
and everybody would be together
for a week, and we'd socialize.
And even if you only worked
with somebody or other
on your team a little
bit, just the fact
that you'd had some
social interaction
and some time together
for a week a year
really strengthened
the online relationship
that you'd go back to.
So I do think that's valuable.
But we're so used to these
momentary touches with people,
whether it's a Twitter DM,
or even just an open tweet,
and a few of your
friends respond,
and you have a little thread.
LinkedIn was built for a certain
kind of online connection,
obviously, and it works
pretty well for that,
for its main purpose.
Instagram, like Twitter,
lets you follow people
you don't know, right?
And you can have a
way to contact them.
These are unlike Facebook,
which was not really designed
for this asymmetrical
networking.
That was much more your
friends and family.
So I do talk in the
book about making
use of those, whichever
ones you're comfortable on,
and where people
you're connected to
are on, so that part
of my day every day
is probably a few Twitter DMs,
a couple of text messages,
a couple of Facebook
Messenger posts,
or something like that,
where I'm just saying,
hey, thought of you.
Saw this.
How are you?
Let's talk soon.
It's not a heavy lift, and it's
not an obligatory response.
It's more just like, I'm
thinking of you right now.
LOUIS GREY: So you mentioned
asymmetrical connections.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And one thing
I want to talk about
is asynchronous versus
synchronous following.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And in the early
days, it was very clear.
In Facebook, I'm
connected to Karen.
Karen's connected to me, and
it can't just be one way.
And Twitter was never the case.
So I could follow you, and you
didn't have to know who I was,
right?
But I would see your updates
and I could respond to you.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And they've made it
so that you can possibly only
see responses from people who
you've already connected to,
or you can filter those down.
But do you see that
there's some kind of value?
Does it even count
as networking to just
be aware of what other
people are doing?
KAREN WICKRE: Yes.
Being aware and curious about
what other people are doing
is definitely a piece
of connecting to people,
because it just
helps you when you--
it gives you context, right,
for when you do have occasion
to meet someone, or
want to meet someone,
that you have a
little more context.
And the context now is richer
than just the job history,
right?
If people have public
accounts, and you
see that a Google alum who's
got an interesting approach I'm
following is Hunter Walk,
who's now at BC with Homebrew.
And so he's posting, he
and his wife and daughter,
like, go to a nail
salon, and they all
get their nails painted.
He's wherever he is.
And so you meet him,
and you think, oh, yeah.
He went to the
Museum of Ice Cream,
or he posted something funny.
That's fair game for
a person you've never
met because he posted
it, and it's public,
and you have a little bit of
ground to be common on together
that you can meet in the
middle and be sociable
about it, personable.
LOUIS GREY: Well,
you mentioned that.
So in your book, you
talk a lot about doing
the minimum standard to get
into one of these networks,
but you have to be authentic.
You can't just tweet a few
links and then disappear.
But you also have people on
the other side of spectrum
who share everything, right?
And they don't stop, and you
mute them, or do whatever,
but they just
continue and continue,
because there's different
personalities that
take place in all
these networks,
including, I think
you said, be it
the communicator, or the person
who pontificates and makes
comments on everything.
KAREN WICKRE: Yes.
LOUIS GREY: How do
you find your lane?
Do you just know what it is?
KAREN WICKRE: No.
OK, here's I tried out now my
favorite quote from the book,
from a guy named Ivan
Meissner, which is,
"Think of networking less like
hunting and more like farming."
Or if you like, substitute
"gardening" for "farming."
So the idea is you're
nurturing, you're watering,
you're planting, you're
trimming, you're weeding,
you're plowing under,
you're replanting,
where hunting is very
transactional, shall we say?
A one-hit.
I built my online
connections over time just
by, oh, this
person's interesting.
I have something in
common with them.
They're interested in
the same things I am.
I didn't meet them,
maybe, at Google,
but I followed them I know
what they're doing now.
I want to be connected.
I mean, it's a long game, right?
And it's a sort
of ongoing process
of cultivation and nurturing.
LOUIS GREY: Sure.
And you talk a little
bit about, or a lot
about loose connections.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And so when you
look at these loose connections,
first of all, you can
define what that means.
And then second, for people
who are a loose connection who
might not have a direct overlap
with a job, does that matter?
Like, do engineers need to
connect to marketing people?
KAREN WICKRE: I would
never mandate such a thing.
No, I mean, it's
based on who you like.
I find an interesting
thing, though,
that in the time since I've
left Google, Google, to me,
is such a world-class network
of people, past and present.
I mean, literally
at the door here,
a guy waved that I
worked with 15 years ago.
I maybe the last time saw
him eight or 10 years ago.
And he couldn't stay today.
I'm going to follow up and
just say, I missed you.
How are you?
It can be very intermittent,
and there's no prescription
about roles or history, even.
It's more just, who
do you like, what
associations you might
have with a place?
I'm sure a company that
fosters and encourages
collaboration and cross-team
work and relationships
and friendships does better
in the long-term networking
realm than one that is
very siloed, just a guess.
LOUIS GREY: And you
talk specifically
about an All-Hands, where people
flew in from around the globe
and met here.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And you still
have relationships today.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: But the reality
is both you and I had dogs,
and wouldn't we rather walk a
dog around the park two times
than go to some
event in the city
and walk around the
room for two times?
I'd rather walk the dog.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: So do I have to
go to this corporate party?
KAREN WICKRE: OK.
So a global off-site is not
probably an optional thing.
It's different than the
holiday party, I would say.
You probably do have
to participate fully
in the off-site,
and that's probably
a good thing all around.
I do write about
corporate parties
because they're not really
networking opportunities,
I don't think.
They may or may
not be obligatory,
but they are more of a
political statement, perhaps.
And by that I mean not
at a company this big,
but at smaller
companies, you need
to be seen as a
team player, right?
You need to be part of the group
and going along with things.
So in a small company,
it's not for fun.
It really is a work obligation
to go to the holiday party.
What I say in the
book is you do not
have to stay all night
at the company party.
Make sure you're seen by
a couple of the people
you need to be seen by,
and then make an exit.
But they're not the same thing.
LOUIS GREY: No, absolutely not.
KAREN WICKRE: Right, yeah.
LOUIS GREY: I was just bridging.
KAREN WICKRE: OK.
LOUIS GREY: OK.
So you also
mentioned in the book
that the people that you
need aren't always those
who are doing the hiring.
So can you explain that?
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
In fact, mostly, you
know how it works.
Mostly, if your friend
says, I've already applied,
and I'd love to meet the
hiring manager, that's just not
going to happen.
That's just not how it works,
especially in a big company.
You don't meet
the hiring manager
before many other steps happen.
But you may want
intel about a team,
or the manager of the team, or
the future of the product line,
or what the dynamics
are of the group, and do
they have cooperation from
the other surrounding groups?
You may want all kinds
of intel about what it's
like to work there, and
who the other people are,
and all that kind of stuff.
So no one person is
going to have, like, here
is the entire answer
to your job quest.
I know everything that
you need to know about it.
It's going to be, like
I said, a long game.
One person has this
piece of the puzzle.
Somebody knows about
the product viability,
or has strong opinions about
it that are somewhat informed.
And someone else has been
on the team for a while.
Someone else can tell
you maybe the history
of how the group has evolved.
Different people along the
way that you might meet,
and so that's how you--
It's like a journalism
effort, really.
You're kind of the reporter
trying to put together
a story for yourself
that makes sense
and that informs your interviews
when you get to that point.
LOUIS GREY: And
so one thing that
has happened, when you
started at Google, it
was literally 17 years ago.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And so the
company's changed, but so
have the products that
are being offered,
and so has the technology.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: And so I think
about this sometimes.
My previous role in
a previous company,
I once asked to have
everybody's birthdays
so that we could publish them
in an internal newsletter.
The enterprising HR
person responded, not only
sent me a bunch of birthdays,
but included their birth year,
and then sorted it from
oldest to youngest.
And I was down at the bottom,
I was like the third youngest
person in the company.
Now, clearly personal
identifiable information,
big mistake.
But I'm no longer the third
youngest person in the company.
KAREN WICKRE: Right.
LOUIS GREY: Neither are you.
LOUIS GREY: And as
things have changed,
you talked about the fact
that 60 is the new 40.
But also, it's really hard
to reboot your career at age
40, or 50, or 60.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah, for sure.
LOUIS GREY: So is
networking more important
because the world is
changing underneath it,
or are you just going
to hold onto your people
and move forward?
KAREN WICKRE: Honestly I have
to say it's more important.
Holding on and hoping no
one's really noticing is--
I mean, that has a limited
success rate, right?
Basically, if you have a growth
mindset, if you're curious,
if you are willing
to evolve, if you're
open to learning new
things, open to meeting
new people, open to having new
thoughts, that's the thing that
keeps you going, correct?
[LAUGHTER]
And in a way, I
used to joke that I
was the oldest person
at Google at the time,
because I am older than Eric.
However, then Google
hired Vint Cerf,
and Vint is older than I am.
So he became kind
of an inspiration
for me, because he's
awesome, and, like,
an insane world traveler
in his three-piece suits.
So we all have age
discrimination.
I do, too.
I will characterize
someone as being too old.
And I mean it's in their mind.
It's like, they don't have
a growth mindset, I guess,
is maybe the way to say it.
But we all have to
kind of watch for that.
But I think the
answer if you fear
it is better step
out a little wider
rather than hope
no one notices me.
LOUIS GREY: Sticking
with demographics
that are uncomfortable for
800, Alex, you are female.
And so as a woman who's
networking, those are--
I mean, you talked about Twitter
being a really hostile place
for women sometimes, and you
kind of railed against it.
I'm not talking about
while you worked there,
but I mean as a platform.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah, I
meant as a platform.
LOUIS GREY: Just to clarify.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: But as a female
who's outwardly networking,
do you find that
it's easier than what
you think your male counterparts
are having it, or is it harder?
Do you find that going out
for coffee or sending an email
sometimes gets the wrong
response or people looking
at it the wrong way?
KAREN WICKRE: So to
me, for me where I am--
I'm 67.
So for me, the age
factor has kind of
trumped the woman factor.
And in a way, that's lucky.
I think it's very interesting
because I was considered
maybe an anomalous person
who worked in Silicon Valley,
but nonetheless,
someone who kind of fit
in, and had been
around a long time.
I had some credibility.
So that helped me.
I was not party to a bunch
of uncomfortable exchanges.
On the other hand,
when you're older,
you're also more invisible.
And in a way, I find that
kind of a superpower,
because nobody pays
attention to you.
And if you're a
woman, they're also
not listening to what you're
saying in a meeting, which
is not always good.
But at the same time,
it's kind of interesting.
Maybe it all ties to being an
introvert, because I observe,
and I watch, and I kind
of take my own counsel,
and kind of react later.
But I can observe the scene
and watch how people are.
But I do think that
for me personally,
I'm sure I wasn't
seriously considered
certain times in my career--
not just at Google,
by any means--
for different roles or
something because some guy
was friends with another guy.
I'm sure that has happened.
But at the same time,
I made my own way.
And I think honestly being a
few years ahead was beneficial
to me, oddly, and
never really got
in my way at all at Google
or Twitter, for that matter.
And earlier on, I was at
a lot of smaller companies
and computer
publications where there
wasn't as much of an age
consciousness gap at that time.
And I didn't have this
yet, so maybe that
made a difference, too.
LOUIS GREY: So when you
introduced your book
in Mountain View, this was
about a couple of months ago?
LOUIS GREY: Yeah, at Books Inc.
LOUIS GREY: Had a book signing.
So I asked you a question,
which I'm going to repeat,
so you're already
ready for this one.
So at Twitter, you
tweet 140 characters.
Now, it's 280.
Maybe you're able add a photo,
but it's pretty concise,
and you're owned
by the container.
And a blog is more open-ended,
but it's not 100 pages.
KAREN WICKRE: Right.
LOUIS GREY: Your book is.
So how did you take on this
uncomfortable challenge
of having to write
for long form?
And obviously, what
you're doing is
kind of like a book tour
and a book signing tour.
These are probably
outside your comfort zone
because you haven't
done it before.
KAREN WICKRE: Right.
LOUIS GREY: How did you do it?
KAREN WICKRE: Well, I knew
enough about publishing to say,
if I get an agent, and they
sell a proposal, I'm in.
I'm going to follow
this adventure.
I know what's generally
entailed here.
I'll do it.
I just thought that.
I did know it would be a problem
to write long, because I'm not
used to writing long.
I've written for online.
A thousand words is more than
enough, most of the time.
So I get the contract, and it
says 60,00 to 80,000 words,
and I thought, I'm just
not going to pay attention
to that right now.
I can't.
But the simple answer
to writing long
is you just have
to break it down.
So I would pay attention
not to the meta length.
I would be more like, follow--
I had to learn how to
make a good outline, which
I hadn't done since school.
And then literally
go to the outline
and say, OK, that's next,
and then that's next.
I mean, that was hard.
That was really butt in
seat type work to make.
And then one day,
my editor said,
let's just count
up how far you are.
And I did it all in Google
Docs, and so she just
did a rough count
of every chapter.
It was like, wow, I'm
at 43,000 words already.
So you will see it's
not a long book.
There's sidebars with exercises.
There's epigraphs
for every chapter,
because that's as long
as it needed to be.
And actually that's what
my editor told me, too.
I didn't have to overly repeat.
But it was a slog.
It was something I had to learn.
Same with going out
and talking about it.
In a way, it's not my
natural state, but--
if I had to do it for the
rest of my life, I don't know.
But for some period
of months or a year,
I enjoy it, because
it's not constant,
and it's fun to talk
about, and especially
to get the questions.
LOUIS GREY: So you talk
a lot about getting
the first role at Google
through people you know,
and using the network, and
helping other people forward.
An similar at Twitter, someone
you knew in your existing
relationship got you there.
So that sets up
this kind of wall
where people who don't
know you can't get in.
And when you talk about Google
getting a million resumes
a quarter, or a day, whatever
it looks like, it's a lot.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
LOUIS GREY: So there's
a two-piece on this.
First does that mean online
job submissions are dead
and recruiters should
just do something else?
And then the third thing
which I'm concerned about
is if you're only getting
in by who you know,
doesn't that just
cement the diversity
problem that we already have?
KAREN WICKRE: That's
a very good question.
But I would say recruiters
are not going away,
because there are still lots of
jobs in the world that follow
this CV submission, picked out
of the pile, phone screening
process that goes on.
The question is really
about the higher-level jobs,
and the executive roles,
and the roles that
are kind of built
on relationships,
and have fostered
relationships with other people
in other places.
That's an interesting
thing to explore.
For me personally,
that's why I'm
open to meeting everybody all
the time and giving advice.
Even if I don't
have direct advice,
I will literally Google
a good how-to article,
and send it to someone, and say,
I can't help more than this,
but this is a good source
for what you need to do next
or what you need to know.
It is a very good question about
the idea of the sort of friends
of friends.
And I don't have a single
good answer to that.
I would say that the more
people in hiring positions
and incumbents at companies
are aware of that,
the more they broadly
network for roles, not just--
the old example
would be Ivy League
is the only place we go, versus
all other kind of schools.
Now, I think we have to
say that they don't all
have to be four-year colleges.
We want to look at a bunch
of different variables.
It's going to just be a
piecemeal improvement, I think,
where someone says, we
are determined to find--
we're going to look
in more sources.
We're going to have a broader
definition of the role,
and we do not want
the friendly person
that we already know we'd
like to have a beer with,
in the famous notion.
In fact, I did interview
an HR executive,
because this question of
cultural fit has come up a lot.
It's kind of shorthand
for they fit with us,
they're like us,
that kind of thing.
And she said that at least in
her circle of HR and training
and development people, they
knew that was a bad construct,
and they don't use that.
They don't want
to reference that.
They think, instead, about
one's cultural contribution
to a company, which could
be narrowly defined,
but hopefully is much more
broadly defined as they have
their passions and
their interests,
and they're not all the
same, and they don't all
match each other.
They're more like
they bring a richness.
So they have a contribution to
make culturally and socially
as well as the job skills.
And I like that way
of thinking about it.
But it takes discipline
to actually apply
that in all the steps
in a hiring process.
LOUIS GREY: And so
you often talk about
having this large
network of connections,
but do you also have
a really tight network
of close connections where
you can be unfiltered?
And is that just a relief to
not have to be this public face?
KAREN WICKRE: Well, for sure.
But I'm not sure I'm this public
face that much of the time,
to be honest.
I mean, we all do when
you actually get together
with someone face-to-face,
you're hopefully
going to be more personal
and more unfiltered than even
watching what you tweet,
or something like that,
or what you choose
to write about.
We all need that, too.
We need the intimacy of the
actual direct connection
as well as, I think, this
broader world that helps
us a lot of things that we do.
So Cliff, I think
we have the option
for anyone else in the audience
who's live to ask questions,
if you do have them.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
Levy, who's great.
What other reporters
were good to work with
and who was bad to work with?
KAREN WICKRE: Well, I mean,
actually, it's interesting.
The whole scene has
changed so much.
It used to be there were the
big mainstream outlets, and then
a bunch of bloggers.
And now, we can't really
make that differentiation
the same way.
So Steven Levy is a wonderful
long-form reporter and not
a day-of scoop-type reporter.
There's actually too many to
name who were covering Google,
but most of the--
maybe this is a fudging
on the question.
I don't know.
But it's a relationship
business too, right?
It's ongoing conversations,
and by the way, not just
when you need something.
It really mirrors the same idea
of connecting with people so
that you can give context,
and be off the record,
and let them know
something's coming
without saying what it is.
And it's very much a good
relationship network.
I would say that
the publications
have changed so much.
Buzzfeed and Vox,
maybe these are
things that didn't exist a
few years ago, VICE sometimes.
There are many more outlets
than the mainstream.
The reporters change,
though, because they're not
in long-term stable
jobs, for the most part,
and so they move around.
So someone like Mike
Isaac, for example,
cut his teeth a little
bit at Recode and "WIRED."
And now, he's at
the "New York Times"
finishing his book on Uber,
which we're all waiting for.
So the cast of characters,
in a way, has changed,
and some of the
practice has changed,
because it's not about--
years before even Google,
for a long time in PR,
it was the long form,
which was magazines
that were three months
out, the short form, which
was newspapers, and then
here came this other thing,
the blogs.
And it's just so much a
different landscape now.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
what your perspective was
on networking
events, where it's--
because you talk a lot about
the current relationships
where you're working
with someone.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But where
you know there's
a networking event
that someone's hosting.
Would you attend it or
not, or what your take is?
KAREN WICKRE: If
it was really just,
like, the purpose of this event
is to make people come home
with business cards or
contacts beamed between phones,
I'd question.
Like, that's like a weird
speed dating kind of thing.
And that's why I think people
hate the idea of networking
is that's what they think
of is hotel ballroom.
I'm going to make
myself stay 30 minutes,
and I'm going to come away
with three business cards,
or whatever.
But if it was a
conference, then that's
a little different, where
there may be common interest.
You might be there
for a day or two.
You're going to have
a little small talk
with this one and that one.
There might be a legitimate
moment of connection.
You wouldn't do a whole
networking thing there.
You'd follow up.
But that's more
natural than just,
like, network to find your
next job at this event that
is about that.
I wouldn't do that,
personally, and I think
they're painful, those things.
I don't know.
Has anyone had a good
experience at one of those?
Does anyone do those?
AUDIENCE: If I could ask you to
summarize the whole book in one
formula, what would it be?
KAREN WICKRE: Well, it wouldn't
be a formula, because I'm
a liberal arts major.
Well, it might be this
guy's quote, Ivan Meissner.
Networking is more like farming
than hunting, to paraphrase.
In other words, it's
seasonal, it's a long game,
and you're continuing
to tend it.
So in essence, I think
that would be what I'd say.
The other thing I might add is
people want to help each other.
It's just you have to
give context and have
some kind of richness around
what you're seeking or asking.
But people like to help
each other if they can.
AUDIENCE: When you reach out
to people, and as an introvert,
I have a problem where you
don't know what to say.
Like, you don't have
a purpose in mind.
Like, what do you do there?
And if you reach out to
people, do they always respond
to you, especially
with people where
you have nothing
really you need to say,
and you don't know
each other that well?
KAREN WICKRE: I think I'd
wonder why you're reaching out
in the first place.
What would make you reach out
to someone you don't know?
AUDIENCE: Like in
general, because--
KAREN WICKRE: Someone
tells you it's a good idea
to make more contacts?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KAREN WICKRE: OK.
You still need context, right?
So if it's just--
like, LinkedIn kind of set this
up in a way that is, I guess,
somewhat useful, but not
entirely useful, right?
Where you send somebody
that canned language.
I'd like to join your network.
Don't do that.
Don't just send a canned
message that's not from you.
They make it easy to
overwrite that and say,
I'm interested in your
career as a product manager.
I'm interested in how
you got to that company,
or you've written
about something
in I. I want to know
more about that.
So you immediately bring some
reason for it to the front.
And that's when people are like,
oh, that's kind of flattering,
and maybe I will respond
to that, however briefly.
No, people do not
always respond,
and that's just the
way it goes, I think.
The law of large
numbers or something,
the more you're trying.
I do find that the better--
your odds are
always better if you
can say, I am a friend of
so and so's, or even better,
your friend introduces you.
But beyond that,
if you say, someone
has spoken highly of
you, or I heard you talk,
or I read your paper.
I would love to have 20 minutes,
or could you respond to this
and send me a link
to your paper,
or could we have a
20-minute call, or if we're
both local, could I
buy you coffee one day,
or something like that?
That it's, like, not a
heavy obligation for them.
There's not a time limit.
And you're saying, I'd
really like to know more.
And maybe you don't
ask it all at once.
Maybe it's just, may I ask you a
few questions about this thing?
And I think people
will respond if they
have that kind of context.
Maybe it's not as
full as you'd like.
Or sometimes, people
will say, yeah.
Actually, based on who you are
and your background, yeah, I
would love to talk shop with
you about it, because I can
see you have some
background that's related,
something like that.
But you do bring something.
You're not asking a favor in
the sense of, please help me.
You're just saying,
I'd like to know more,
or this interests me.
Would you take time
to tell me more?
It's not like, I need a job,
and I have to apply tomorrow.
That would not get a
response, a good response,
most of the time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
So when I read about the history
of companies like Google,
and Twitter, and all these
other technology companies,
how they were started,
how they were founded,
it's usually a story about
a small handful of people
who somehow know each other and
then make this great company.
And when you read about like,
oh, how do you start a startup,
it always skips that step.
It's always like,
you have your team.
And now, make your startup.
Here's the steps, how you
get venture capital funding,
and all these other things.
How do you go from
having this network
that you've cultivated
to having, like,
a team that you can use
to actually take steps
to start things like this?
KAREN WICKRE: It's a
very good question.
I mean, I'm only
speaking as an observer
here of the same history
you're talking about.
But it seems like probably the
first thought isn't a company,
but like, is it a product?
Is it a thing we can make
that's interesting, if it's
engineers and technical people?
And money doesn't come
into it for a while,
but it's more like,
is this a good idea?
Is this something either
interesting, or groundbreaking,
or does something different
with technology in some way?
Google's pretty unusual in
that most companies don't
have an early team of employees
that is as cohesive for as long
as has been the case at Google.
That's really rare, I think.
And so typically,
it's more like,
the Beatles, where it's like,
it was Stu Best, but he died.
Or, I mean, Stu Sutcliffe.
He died, and then
it was Pete Best,
but he didn't kind of work
out, and we didn't like him,
and so then it was Ringo.
It's like, when I read
about companies starting,
it's often, OK, this was
the beginning, and then--
in fact, I just met a guy who
said, I was part of a startup.
It was successful,
but I realized
I didn't want to
do it, so I bailed.
I sold my half to the
other ones, and I'm out.
People shift around.
But essentially, it
does come from either,
we have a good
idea because we've
been fooling around together
and come up with something.
Or in a lot of cases now,
it's like, we worked somewhere
on something before,
but we always
had this thing we talked about
as a thing we'd like to try.
But there are so many steps
between that and even VC
or anything becoming a company.
Lots don't obviously
get that far.
But it is interesting what
you're saying, though,
about it is kind of your
personal network of people
you know well at first.
You're not discovering people
on Instagram for your company.
It's people you know and
trust in the beginning,
and think deeply about stuff.
And then it's a long, long
journey after that, I think.
And so how that happens?
I mean, we're lucky
to live in a place
and in a time when there's
so many things that
are, like, incubators,
and angel investors,
and small accelerators,
and things that
are for very early stage,
just fooling around
startups that are not
formulated at all,
but it's a few people trying
to figure something out.
And by the way,
they're networking,
and talking to other people,
and testing out their ideas.
So it's very hit and
miss, but I think
that's what, I don't
know, makes it seem--
LOUIS GREY: I'm going to say
it's a small conversation that
turns into an idea.
KAREN WICKRE: Yeah.
That's a good way of saying it.
[APPLAUSE]
It's great to be here.
It's really great.